[Music]
and if you haven't noticed everybody
we've got indian food today which means
we have a very special guest thank you
as you can see i always
travel with a plate of 10
it's on your writer it's this form of id
it's like got blue m m's it's like santa
claus but the indian version and he has
a lot of tandoori chickens he's just
getting santa's clothes
claws everybody welcome back to another
but we like to keep it extremely careful
um so i hear something
somewhere about a doll that was made of
you a sexy doll do you have your own
doll dude yeah
no no no uh i did a cool little project
with uh an incredible artist uh tanya
oh sorry
once you said the name the joke was out
yeah i know we had to get
real on here for a second uh
she photoshopped me into a ken doll
you guys can see on buzzfeed is it
life-size because once it's life-sized
you know what's up
maybe if you pay enough money maybe
you'll get a lesson i'm gonna sit on
that doll's face
like the dog could experience pleasure
yeah we'll see that's just like the
marketing tagline sit on my face yeah
yeah you could just hang out with me
i got the real one who needs a [ __ ]
doll dude you got the first edition
right here
you could already do that at jiu jitsu
together i know dude what was the
process like of getting him into a doll
uh so she it was more it was all
photoshopped but yeah
we did green screen photo shoot uh
had a stylist make a part of the whole
team yeah uh and it was a lot of you
know we're gonna hit these poses and do
these things with the joints and then
she went in and she went and uh
photoshopped it so did are they making a
doll out of that like a prototype i
don't think so but we could talk just
made a real list we could talk to mattel
and make it happen maybe they'll sell
mattel's
make some
sell some dolls make that happen
you just need to create another company
called patel and then
it's the indian
barbie
sponsored by athletic greens can i see a
picture of the dog can we see a picture
yeah is it googleable yeah yeah it is
what is it sex dolls just type in ritesh
ritesh sex doll kendall
kendall
buzzfeed
there it is really wanted to be here
he really
he just wants to have something yeah joe
yeah get in line but it's really it's
really cool looking work man
this is it right here ladies there's
just a there's a better one oh there's a
better one
okay for just go to the website you're a
good pr guy for yourself uh just go to
the website
go to the website i'm going to show them
how to use a computer
compared to margot robbie what is this
this is the article oh
he's like i haven't read an article in
years i just stare at pictures
is that you why are you so that's real
life you look so [ __ ] in this photo
that's from russian doll okay
this is the one okay they made a russian
doll no the tv show he's on his show oh
that's right
you'll see the ones with like the joints
and my neck
that'll be a funny rotten russian doll
where you just keep
it
you're like more retention
he's like in a pinball shape are you
playing golf yeah this is like an ode to
the classic ken
that's tight
1950s 1960s um
yeah it's pretty cool that's some of the
other photos you can see the the joint
locks and my head
and all that stuff i remember for like
school projects back in elementary
school i remember love i'd love making
clouds like that
[ __ ] taking cotton balls
here we go this is cute as [ __ ]
i saw that one yeah i take him to prom
am i right yeah
come on baby
so it was a great great project um tanya
did an incredible job she's an amazing
artist
uh she's inspired a lot by pop culture
and isn't she like some kind of crazy
engineer or some [ __ ] she was
she used to work for nasa no
yeah yeah and then she kind of did a
career switch much smarter than to do
photoshop she was like yes when you
could do this am i right she uh she did
a residency uh through adobe so this was
her final project her capsule project
yeah i like that one
yeah so we got a little foot rest
popcorn's on the floor though i don't
know how i feel about popcorn on the
floor well these got to fill the
negative space
[Laughter]
never heard of golden ratio idiot
he's resting dude and it's like
i'm probably watching your show on the
tv action figure i just thought we we
come on to the show to like have
opinions as steve says this is what
happens when a dancer hosts a show man
he doesn't like popcorn on the floor
because it might [ __ ] up his floor
glides
too much butter floor glides
i'm just saying how many guys were
popping on the floor they should make
that into a video game
the kendall can and yeah kendama dodgy
popcorn if i could create a video game
i think it would be like a uh
like because we were talking about
yakuza or like gta right
but
you have you ever played a hentai game
it's like choose your own destiny
absolutely you got to try to [ __ ] them
right
and i think that's what we got to do you
guys are giving me [ __ ] for popcorn on
the floor just gotta ask you if you
haven't played a hentai game for all the
games we grew up want to remember that i
just i just it's a segway you played a
hentai game before oh yeah
not in the late night so what was the
storyline that's the first question was
it pc or was it like was it a rated g
bird game or no it was like absolutely
not rated sex but it's like i'm a new
student at this new school
oh man there's so many hot girls and
then it's like you just try to ask a
girl on a date is that wolfenstein like
sideways no it's like it's like graphic
jean kimono while you were playing this
game i just noticed what you were
wearing like i had is it when you call
it isn't it
it was similar to this but like one arm
was tucked in like that so you could
just be
ready to go
and my pants were around my ankles
and then my mouse was i got really good
at jacking off with my left hand because
i'll do it like this
dang wow
so let's play this inside game we should
do a react video should we do a group
collection it's basically you choose
your own destiny right so then they'll
give you a multiple choice they'll ask
you a question and then you can choose
how to respond to her and then it's an
interactive game where you always you
were always a gentleman i would imagine
see if you're too nice
then it goes bad and you gotta start
from the beginning
yeah you're like oh you come on too fast
too hard they're like ah
too horny i don't want you i don't want
to talk to you so there's there's an
optimal approach so it teaches you games
and it teaches you seduction i think
kids need this decent i think we should
bring this game back kids is a strong
word but yes there's nothing enough
there's too many i think kindergarteners
need this i forgot the name of it but
there's like once you get like ready and
flirty right um there there's an outline
of her and then you gotta choose what to
what order do you kiss first do you
touch the boo first do you do whatever
right but horny boys they would like go
straight and try to like [ __ ] touch
her [ __ ] or something and go burn she
puts her clothes back on and then like
you gotta start from the beginning
wow you have to go and like maybe you
got to be romantic all the time you
spent wasting playing this game yeah now
you gotta go back to the multiplayer
beat it in one try nah dude it was hard
you know but then looking online to find
all the answers in order
there were hard ones like that there was
one there was one uh called paradise
heights and it's like you you're this
new guy in an apartment complex where
every unit has a different hot girl and
the the objective paradise baby and the
game is like it's like a narrative that
lasts like i don't know months and
you're basically trying to get every
girl without them knowing that you're
trying to get the other one this is the
hey thing about this thing about this
that there's someone out there who was
like i'm going to design this game and
not only will people play it it's going
to do really [ __ ] well
like you know you're like this is a
great idea if i feel like i pitched a
video game like this to anyone they'd be
like this is a harvest when i was 17
that's like that was everyone's fantasy
you know i mean in your mind you're like
oh i could be that guy just get caught
in an apartment building yeah yeah yeah
when you're [ __ ] 16 years old
eligible bachelors and bachelorettes
this is uh that was your dream this is
apparently a scene or one of the
screenshots from paradise i just
no way yeah that's it that's the that's
the weird ass 90s pc graphics man what's
in his balls actually no i didn't even
realize that was a purge in kettlebell
kettlebell
no he has an erection and his it's going
through the fly of his pants but he has
underwear
no it's not blurred out well no look at
the it's the boxers dude
looking at it like it's a [ __ ]
delicious corn dog that she's about to
develop so big in that
because you've never seen one that's
before
notice the gentle hand placement on top
of that i think she's really admiring
probably like the cotton thread count
oh like her eyes
he's like a seamstress also there's no
button on his fly very interesting
hat it's obviously a late stage of the
game by that scene because that's does
it is it just still the same format
where it's multiple choices
no one made fun of this game there must
be like made fun this is art it's such
an underground like weird niche thing
like called summer heights high what was
going on these are like late 90s hentai
you had to download it from kazaa wow
not even limelight i got the i used to
source that on aol like i used to when
so your computer was riddled with
viruses is what you're telling us yeah
hold on
no one told me about these games does it
get significantly more mature or is it
oh it does it just becomes porn but it's
pixelated dude did you guys learn
anything by the end of your experience
seriously did you learn one positive
thing was there a carryover and this is
the evil thing you learned because every
single girl they go to such lengths of
making them so different
personality-wise they're all different
archetypes and tropes of women that you
learn what these women would rather hear
so your options are always different
you're never saying the same thing to
each girl you're saying things catered
to what our hobbies are with the nerds
yeah like
so really good training so i think it's
taught you guys to be better listeners
or at least to you know because you had
to pay attention to each of these
individuals some people might say that
you're giving them a lot of credit i am
not one of those i'm i'm just trying to
save their career it teaches you it
teaches you late 90s womanizing i think
kids need this man
that's what i'm saying did you let tyka
play this game yeah so he's going to
turn into an incel yeah yeah not now
he's too young to make sure he got game
that's why i said kids was a strong word
he's like when he's like
yeah yeah that's a good yeah i think i
played it in junior high
i was in junior high when i i was like
12 when i played that game whenever i
discovered jacking off see when i was 12
i was playing
probably like diddy kong racing
that is not even mario kart you're an
intel dude you were probably picking the
hovercraft too here i am
speaking of games didn't you just win an
award for one
yeah he set that up wow that was good
uh yes
tribeca had their festival a couple
weeks ago we won best video game it
might i think this is the first time
ever i don't know you guys on the
internet uh it's called thirsty suitors
outer loop games also downloadable on
kazan
[Laughter]
unopported interactive uh it's a great
game features a
south asian family
it's about a female protagonist who has
to go back and um
kind of right the wrongs in her previous
relationship which one are you
so i play a villain
sergio i was in the door you're the guy
with a white sleeveless jacket guys are
at home looking up thirsty suitors is
this you yo that guy looks like bart
dude to the right that you got purple
hair guys
trailer is out everyone check it out
when it drops
no release date yet but shout out to our
team there's a bard in there i think you
guys will really dig it because it's
it's once again really quirky and off
the walls
and uh
deals with uh south asian culture and
you see a penis coming through denim
jeans
but it's pretty good football bar as
long as it doesn't deal with mental
health it's pretty good it's pretty good
bless you
where can we play this on uh my
understanding it'll be out on all the
concerts wait what is it what do they is
they play football it's an rpg
what do you guys play soccer in this
game it's like madden except without
this class this guy heard nerf football
goes right in line with your your game
that you were playing thirsty suitors
this is like the you know
you're a thirsty suitor
that's amazing in fact you guys we all
could be these characters in real life
okay who's so obviously bart is that guy
is there fighting yeah i like fighting
yes it looks dope actually let me try
and put two together if it works like
this um so you were saying uh tribeca
films dropped the films because now they
do uh gaming and stuff like that yeah
was all the stuff you're doing with ken
is that under tribeca
no the ken stuff was just a independent
project okay so uh so this was for like
the other movies that you were a part of
um tribeca so tribeca what we what i
went for was for this specific game
thursday oh okay okay so this is like a
separate thing that you just happened to
just a separate project a man does
robert de niro show up at tribeca
in this exact outfit
with your hentai game and you ask him to
sign it on your gameboy or whatever you
play
i gotta get my film glasses on yeah all
right let's do it wow dude you look like
a character from yakuza like a dragon oh
thank you yeah you can go a lot like
straight up either he like made a
genocide elite like straight up [ __ ]
thing
how about that even more dude no for
real you look like yakuza you like
you've equipped every possible yeah is
it yakuza or is it yakuza it's yakuza
yakuza
it's yakuza
you can't say it you can't say it
without yelling again yakuza or
[Laughter]
so we should all just speak in our
native accents or heritage accents
nobody though
that's yours
so how did you get involved in this game
are you auditioned and they were
you know gracious enough to cast me and
i was lucky enough to be in it and
that's cool
i didn't know like i went in it was a
fun little thing did you help develop it
too no no no no i just came in as an
actor had no idea what it was about it's
really kind of goofy and off the wall um
i love it so i highly recommend everyone
check it out so when did robert de niro
give you the the trophy
he's gonna show up later today i told
him to meet me out here i mean how are
you gonna have a film festival and you
don't even attend you know what i mean
like that's kind of weird to me
that's his film probably he probably
doesn't care i don't know
probably doesn't care
if i had a film festival i'd be like
there every single time you should start
one star one post what if you did it
like
20 years in a row these things still
keep going like what
it's once a year right so it's only 20
times you go
i think you should start an award show
for your favorite hentai material
[Laughter]
we're on to something video games
comic books anime why don't i do a a top
joe's top 10 picks of porno of the week
i mean you already
looked the part make it into a top five
yeah and then you'd really deep dive and
you already live with all of the kind of
like the world judging you like you
already do that so you might as well you
know double jeopardy and i think to open
it up you need to have the categories
and then you have an overall winner like
you know so you have
lesbian gay straight
objects you know so you have the
category winners and then you have an
overall they're like yo you hear
joe's new top five this month it's so
good i'm gonna have this most of the
radius
professional you gotta be careful once
you expand past hentai people like this
is not authentic anymore really you got
too real yeah it got too real oh yeah do
you have a dream game that you'd like to
voice on or like a
franchise like paradise heights besides
gta i think you'd be a good gta vice
city voice i mean i think being part of
a franchise would be really cool just
any franchise like anything furious
sorry you said games yeah games
i'm surprised they didn't even make that
a game yet they did but they suck
they're for kids it's hard to do the
movies into the game it's like they're
like kids games but you know i love halo
i love gears of war
i love metal gear solid
that would be fun metal gear solid
because i want to do a game where you
talk a lot well because melody
charlotte's good because you have to
actually act yeah don't they just final
fantasy but the thing is final fantasy
like
i don't know maybe most people play in
japanese i think we should create the
game that we're talking about earlier
indian jones where he goes into the
british indiana jones india jones
i steal back all the indians all the
indian artifacts they steal it revenge
yeah from the temple of doom what is
that what's the actual jewel you said i
don't know
there's some there's some jewels
somewhere in probably london most
valuable jewel like the biggest jewel i
i don't know if it's a ruby or sapphire
and it's originally an indian treasure
yeah and it's probably sitting in some
british museum chilling let's start a
heist yeah let's do a heist crew this is
what our heists move should we just
steal all the asian artifacts and bring
them back to the wrong asian countries
we don't even this is for you this is
chinese we're japanese who had the shiva
was it you
who let this send that back where's this
ganesh go [ __ ] we're in indonesia
ganesha's at a cambodian thing here you
go
what if you show up and it's like you
know how those different empires right
so it was like a different dynasty and
they're like not even the same chinese
that was rolling so they're like that
ain't us like what the [ __ ] who do i get
though we can sell this on the market
for a lot of money and we bring it to
pawn stars to see how much oh yeah that
was the premise of our heist movie
remember yeah steel they got it they got
a crown
stars you just have the worst fence i
got an indian jewel guy yeah yeah the
best thieves with the worst fence what
if we just set them up what if we
there's only like we bring such specific
material to the pawn stars guys that
there's only one expert and we're all in
on it together and they're like really
this is priceless but if i had to put a
price on this 100 billion dollars
and then he'll be like well i can only
sell it for a billion because or i can
only buy it for a billion because i need
them i'll give you a good deal i still
need to make money at the end of the day
oh you're twisting my arm here okay
[Music]
you